shrek forever after the final film in
the shrek legacy i guess is it as good
as the second one is it as bad as the
third one i think it's kind of somewhere
in the middle out of all the movies i
say this one is probably the second best
but then again i don't really think much
of the other movies apart from the
second
it appears shrek is now a family man
he's living back at the swamp with his
wife and children and at first it seems
pretty nice but then day after day after
day of doing the exact same thing
finally starts to wear on him to a point
where he says he just can't take it
anymore he has a blow-up with his family
and comes across a little man named
Rumpelstiltskin he makes a deal with
shrek that he can give him one day to do
whatever he wants as long as he can just
take one day away from his life Trek
agrees and when Juno it the one day
taken from his life was the day he was
born
so now shrek lives in a reality where he
doesn't exist and Rumpelstiltskin rules
the land nobody knows who he is and he
has to convince everybody that he's a
good guy
donkeys a slave gingerbread man is a
cracker that's the best lie in the movie
what are you talking about cracker and
fiona is now the leader of the
resistance of ochres the film in no way
reaches the Harter comedy that ii had
but at the same time i will admit i did
sort of want to know what was going on I
was more intrigued with how shrek was
gonna get out of this and the alternate
reality that was created from his
decision I like seeing the characters in
different roles I like seeing them do
different things the downside is that
doesn't really lead to a lot of funny
moments and I mean that sort of in the
same way as the first film like it's
almost not trying to be that funny it's
more trying to just tell the story
straight up which isn't necessarily bad
I much rather they try to tell a good
story than just have to try to tell a
bunch of jokes that really fail there
are a few good laughs in this so I guess
my only two major problems with this
movie is one the fact they could use a
lot more jokes yeah it's a comedy I do
think that's bit of a problem and to
this scene all I want is for things to
go back to the way they used to be you
mean back before you rescued me from the
Dragons keep exactly I think the scene
where Shrek blows up at Fiona is way too
out of character and way too
mean-spirited even for shrek it just
didn't feel right I mean I know
he says boiling point but no this this
doesn't work we're supposed to still
like this guy and feel sorry that he
said this stuff but when you say things
like that that's pretty nasty and I
think that really does harm a lot of the
film even though it's just a small scene
but for everything else I guess it's an
OK film I mean for a movie that really
didn't need to exist I can't really say
it's bad I want to know what was gonna
happen I like the villain of the movie I
like the alternate outcomes but nothing
really screams go see it - me either
so my thought is if you just sort of
want to see the Shrek movies just to
finish up the Shrek movies you won't be
that disappointed it's got a laugh here
or two and it will keep your attention
however if you're looking for a really
good strong comedy with really good
strong characters you might want go back
to the second one not the best not the
worst take it for what it is
you